Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call and just a reminder about where to find things. So you got to the Zoom call I presume through the member site.
So last week there was a little confusion with somebody asked a question and I said you'll find it on the homepage of the member site.
It's the main of the member site and I think they were looking for what they were looking for on our website. So there's a different street cutters clinic website that's available in the public and the member site that's available only to members.
So the member site is that where you have the login to get to the site. There's a number of pages. Zoom call page where you can see all the past Zoom calls and the login to this Zoom call that you're on.
The homepage of that member site is where you'll see announcements what's new you'll see other things on that homepage that is pertinent to everybody immediately.
So just different, different between the members site when I say it's on the member site versus on the website. So that's the difference.
Okay, easy thing to confuse sometimes. All right, let's jump right in.
First question, you reviewed my last ultrasound down to 524 a month or so ago. We discussed the change in the main mass from 4.0.
By 1.7 by 1.2 to 4.5 by 2.6 by 1.4. These were also done in a different facility by different technicians. Combined with labs and lack of other symptoms, you were very reassuring.
Today, my functional doctor called not a cancer doctor. She's out of her element. She admits to report that she was told by the radiologist. Apparently, his big concern was the size of the mass of the axillary mass, which grew from 6 by 3 millimeters last year to 8 millimeters this year.
And I don't know if you know what the other dimension was. So is this a lot for the lib note, especially considered different machine, different tech.
So if it grew to 8 by 3 or 8 by 5, so it grew 2 millimeters in the course of the year, is that a lot? No, that's not a lot.
So if it so what a lot of growth would be like a double lead in size and 3 to 6 months.
Still, if it doubled in size over 12 months, I'd still say that's cause for concern.
When you're talking a couple of millimeter difference, there's that much room for error reading. So remember always that you think of it that your cancer isn't square nor is it perfectly rectangular.
It's not a rectangle, grow it in your armpit or in your breast or in your liver. It is a blob. And the blobs have, you know, think of a blob of of clay.
If you squashed it all over with your fingers and you and then you tried to take measurements, well, how would you measure that?
So what angle you're looking at what angle you're holding that blob of clay is there's a lot of room for discrepancy.
So what you're looking at changes in size, you're looking at changes that are relatively large. Also, even if it doubled in size, let's say, that would be a cause for concern.
It wouldn't necessarily by itself be a cause for changing a course of care or changing a course of treatment in everybody's case.
Why? Because you don't just look at one marker. So one marker would be one test, one lab, one CT scan, one, you know, you look at other things.
Why? Because other things can appear, can give you false impressions. It's the best way to put it.
What do you mean by that? Well, okay, when you're measuring a mass with an ultrasound or CT scan or an MRI, the mass can appear larger by the way you measure it, by dimensions that you're using as far as the angle that you're looking at.
There's so many variables that way, but the mass can also appear larger if the mass is died. It might not be growth that's causing the enlargement.
Maybe it's a immune flare around the cancer that is a purine larger. So I personally had patients that had a cancer mass in larger than they go into surgery.
And it wasn't the cancer that was enlarged. All the cells were dead. It was a immune response around it. That's possibility too. That is always the case. But these are the things that you have to consider.
That's why you never just take one test and make your clinical decision. She would like to finish a question.
She would like me to get another opinion given all that I'm doing and my lack of progress. She mentioned other alternative doctors.
Absolutely. You can get another opinion for sure, but this phrase concerns me all that I'm doing and my lack of progress.
So this is where non-cancer doctors and laypeople can make mistakes and thinking that you don't have progress because the cancer isn't shrinking.
So that would I think what she is defining as progress. Why isn't the cancer shrinking? Okay. Remember cancer is cells there in rapid replication. If it's no longer rapidly replication, it rapidly replicated the rate of its increase in size is going to go down.
I think the larger the cancer is if the cells are all in rapid replication, it's going to get larger faster as time goes on. So if the course of one year, it's changed a couple of millimeters, I would say that most of the cells are no longer cancerous. Why would you say lack of progress?
Yeah, that's ignorance in understanding what cancer is. I might discourage you for getting another opinion. Absolutely not. Go get another opinion. Go get other tests if that would make you feel better. Do it MRI. Do a PET scan. Do other objective testing to give you some sense that you're staying on the right way if you want to look at other clinics, then absolutely you should do that.
You know, as a believer, you should be praying about your decisions, not making decisions based on false security, but not making decisions based on fear either. So look into those. This person asked another question a little bit later. I think it's this one.
Just locked up your own bed clinic. Their approach is something called a George protocol after Dr. Frank George, which combines insulin, potentiated chemotherapy, which is chemotherapy given with insulin. So that the cancer cell would uptake the chemotherapy a little bit quicker. They could use 10% dosage with powerful homeopathic immune modulators specific to each patient's cancer. Well, that sounds delightful. I mean, that sounds like a great approach.
So if a person wants to do chemotherapy but doesn't want to do high dose chemotherapy, then insulin potentiated chemotherapy is a different option and a good option anytime you're using a specific only a path like that. So even a better option is that.
But you got to weigh it out. You're going to probably have to move down there for three months because typically, of course, if insulin potentiated chemotherapy is at least 36 months.
So just got to weigh all that out. If that's the right thing for you, then by all means look into that. What do you think about those vibration plate machines? Are they good for keeping the lymph system moving to help with circulation to move core strength by doing exercise on them or any other real benefits to help?
Excuse me, I had to take a drink there.
The vibration plate machines are great. So typically, those are called vibe plates. You're standing on this machine and it's vibrating. The benefit of it is multifold from a lymphatic system standpoint.
It's causing what's called muscular fasciculation, which is these teeny contractions of your muscles. So actually, standing on a vibe plate for five minutes is like walking for 20 minutes or something like that.
It is great way to contract your muscles, which thereby will help with lymph flow and the simple vibration is going to help with lymph flow help with your circulation can build core strength, just like you said, especially if you're doing exercises on them.
Also is a great stimulation for your cerebellum. Your cerebellum is the back part of the brain, which controls all your frontal motor cortex function goes through the cerebellum and cerebellar issues can be very common.
So the only thing that I'd say you'd be careful with them with is that you just go slow. Are there any contraindications to vibe machines? Yes, if you have like metal hip replacement or knee replacement, it could be too much vibration, could irritate that could possibly dislocate that you have to be careful with that.
If you have any brain issues, frontal cerebellar issues, you have to go really slow, maybe only a minute at a time on it, even at that you should start really slow anyhow, because it is a pretty strong cerebellar stimulation.
So go real slow in starting and they can be great machines, they can be great for your brain, they can be great for all sorts of things.
So starting the metastasis of cancer to the lungs question from last week, I've tried the nebulized hydrogen peroxide as described by Marcola.
Since I do this, how long and how often should I do this?
So your little nebulizer should only fill up about an ounce of fluid, you do that, it takes about 10 minutes, maybe 15 minutes to get through that nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
I would do this three, four times a day if you want, I wouldn't do any longer than that, I wouldn't do any more than that.
But certainly, you could do it three or four times a day, space it out a couple hours between times that you're doing that.
I would say yes, can you do nebulized iodine or nebulized baking soda for alkalization?
I don't know, you'd have to look up a recipe for baking soda.
That's a possibility, I don't know the recipe for that iodine, you could, I don't think iodine is going to be a drug killer for cancer that's in the lungs though.
So I would not do the iodine, I would stick to hydrogen peroxide.
You could do colloidal silver, that's typically more if you have an infection, you're talking about cancer.
If you could find a recipe for baking soda, that would be fine and hydrogen peroxide, it's ticked to those.
My oncologist has me on lupron for metastatic prostate cancer, and now wants me to take Zatiga daily.
Zatiga is, I remember correctly, that's a daily drug for testosterone, energy deprivation therapy.
I remember you had some reservations on Zatiga.
It wasn't Zatiga that I had reservations on, I think when we were speaking, it was the bone drug.
But in your opinion, what would be the long term use of this product on my body?
On the member site, back to the member site again, on the member site, there is a link to a search bar of drug from drugs.com, where you can search the side effects of all medication, I would do that.
Long term effects of energy deprivation therapy is less and less testosterone, and the long term effect is the inability to get your testosterone back post treatment.
If you're tolerating it well, and you're not having any issues from it, then I'd say continue if you're not tolerating it well, then you've got to think about continuing with energy deprivation therapy.
Also, I have some concern in taking 300-milligram capsules of the B-17 daily with meals.
According to some literature, no one should take more than 10 apricot curtles per day, which average is about 200 milligrams.
Well, that's interesting, because all the literature for cancer is people are taking 20 to 50 apricot curtles per day.
The average apricot curtle is 20 milligrams, and being exposed to so much side, I have 1500 milligrams of B-17.
If you have issues with it, there are some people that are taking more than this and have no issues.
There are some people that don't detoxify it well, and they're getting some liver issues at this dosage.
If you have concerns about it, you could just start with one of those a day. That's just fine.
B-17 amygdala is an oxidative therapy for cancer. It can be very beneficial, and you certainly don't take 1500 milligrams for months and months and months.
Usually, I have people on it for several months at a time, and then we drop off to a different therapy.
If you feel have concerns about it by all means, you've got to make that old decision yourself. I'm just giving you an information about what came up on your testing.
So there's a lot of people after we do a cheek swab testing.
Funny is some people like, hey, have me do cheek swab testing, I do that for them come up with a protocol and they never end up buying supplements and ever in supplements and ever follow through with anything I recommended.
You don't know, I mean, that's okay. If you feel like I'm leading you in a different direction, that's just fine.
But, you know, there's lots of people that do pay for our whole program and then don't seem to do anything.
Lots of people that we've gotten right machines back from family members of patients that started with us, and we've never heard from them since they started in a pass away in the year too later.
We get the right machine back and I am a way of looking at it and I realize they never even used the thing.
I don't know, I don't know why people make the decisions. I want you to be praying about your decisions.
If you really feel like, I think that's too much for me, then by all means, started a lower dosage.
I want you to be responsible. I don't want you to, Dr. Carter said to this, so I'm going to do it.
I don't want to have that type of relationship with you. That's the type of relationship that the medical professional wants to have with you.
They want you to do exactly what they tell you. They are somewhat next to God-like, and they want you to think that and they want you to tell this and everything they say.
I'm just giving you my semi-educated opinion in everything.
I certainly don't know everything. What I make recommendations about your cheek swap test is just what's tested on you that day that we got that cheek swap.
That can change over time too. If you feel like God's leading you in a different direction as far as dosage or something else, you feel like you should add on.
I said this hundreds of times on this Zoom call where people say I really feel like I really feel led to take this to what do you think?
And I said, and I won't do that by all means. You need to be listening to God and having that relationship with him that you can really feel like he's leading you.
That's what I want from you most of all.
I have a question already. Any questions coming in on the chat. Otherwise, we're going to have a shorter Zoom call today.
Okay, you guys are going to let my voice my throat recover.
I am losing two pounds per week. Okay, well, that's not that's not good.
Two pounds per week in your eating everything you can. That's not good. We should have a phone conversation. So we don't want a person.
So a person can be in weight loss with cancer because they made drastic changes in their diet and they're overweight when they start.
And making those drastic changes and making lifestyle changes, you could go into a weight loss where you're losing a couple of pounds a week because of those changes.
If you're still above your normal weight or what you would ideal, your ideal weight that I wouldn't be too concerned about that.
Or if it's coming from those dietary changes, if you're already at your ideal weight and you're still losing weight, then that's a concern.
We need to address that. So your schedule of time with you if that fits into your category.
Okay, ask you about this last week, but you didn't recall receiving the question. The question was their right programming for this.
I thought I answered that question last week and I thought I was going to program program for you wasn't that I think that's what I was supposed to do.
Okay, so I think if he's on the call, if you can remind me, let me do a Stuart chat to myself.
Chronic fatigue, so groom program.
Okay, so I will look that up if I can find that I will create a program for you for them.
Love is a rebounder just as good as the vibration plate for lymphatics or you just have to do it for longer for lymphatics.
So the vibration plate the benefit of the vibration plate is you get the muscle fasciculation just by standing on the plate you're not doing any exercise.
Now, you can exercise on a vine plate and then you're getting the benefit of still the muscle fasciculation and the contraction of muscles depending on what exercises you're doing.
So by far, the by plate is more efficient.
What's better to move lymph?
Well, that's that's a difficult question to answer. I still probably say the vine plate.
Probably, just because it's more efficient. So in the same amount of time that you're on the rebounder versus on the by plate, you're going to probably get a lot more muscle contraction on the by plate.
2.5 months on to box fit in 1.5 months on loop run, having a hard time feeling the axillary lumps at all side effects are not that bad, very grateful that things seem to be going well.
So that's very good news. So you going totally in the right direction is always always very good news, especially we are having side effects from medication.
So most premenopausal women have severe side effects from to moxipin. So it's what a blessing that you're not probably everything else you're doing.
You are supposed to get me some info. Okay, I won't do that. Thank you so much.
I set myself a note. So if you don't hear anything by early next week, make sure you just call the office and remind Marine to remind me to do that.
All right, many other questions.
Referring to our full consult Monday, the lymph in the report, you said is a lymph behind the heart. What's kind of.
Yeah, the test was abdominal ultrasound. So it's actually behind a right above the diaphragm, you can actually Google that word.
And you can see probably find a picture. If you look at images, you'll find a picture of where that lymph node area is.
It's right above the diaphragm, right behind the intravenic ava.
So you'll be able to see that. So it's near the heart today area is difficult to get out surgically.
So Google did not understand. Well, just make sure you type it correctly.
From that report, the coral lymph node area.
So I know you'd be able to fight it because it is an anatomical position.
I have a coral right here, coral region listed right there. So I just googled it and you can find it right there on Google.
When you meet with me about when I was asking you about recurrent rash, you said you would do some research on that.
Yes, the recurrent rash that you were having, the couple possibilities that I came up with was possible viral infections as one cause a recurred rash.
It's possible that so when you're exposed to something that stimulates in a mute response like a bug bite or a poison ivy, if you get these rashes or something that stimulates a cytokine response, a very strong cytokine response.
And the person gets a rash for a period of time. The other thing that I was looking at some literature is that it's possible that it's that there's a viral connection.
So the problem with viruses is that some of them are possible to kill some people some theories are that they may not even be living organisms.
So it's you can basically knock them down, but they can never go away.
You can basically test every single person in the world for Epstein bar and 90 some percent of the people will test positive for Epstein bar.
Why do people once you have once you get a herpes virus that leads to cold source.
Why do you get cold source them throughout your life, when you expose to lemon water or something like that because the virus lives in the ganglion of the nerve and it just comes out in opportunistic times.
Well, sometimes those opportunistic times for a virus might be a change in pH like like a herpes of the mouth, but some opportunistic times are when there's a huge cytokine response.
So that's a possibility.
You could try running the viral complex to see if that is it there's also Epstein bar there's other viruses so we don't know if it's Epstein bar, but Epstein bar is very common.
I'm running that program. I think there's a psoriatic program. Oh, the one question I was going to ask with you with that rash, do you get any other symptoms with it like joint pain?
That could give us different clues to different issues too.
If there's any other symptoms that you get with it, then that can give you an idea what possibly it is no like fatigue or anything like that with it.
That would point more to Epstein bar then I would still maybe just run that instead if that's not it, then I would run the viral complex.
See if that helps knock it down, you could also run the parasite all kill frequency.
Was that numbers a wide range of different parasite frequencies yet that is yet.
Those are the things that I would try if I were you.
Is there anything you do about the numbness around my axillary area from my mastectomy surgery last September or is it too late?
And doing some dry brushing is there a right program. I also touch one area. I feel weird zing feeling that another I figure it's just nerves.
I would say most likely yes, it's just nerves and when they do surgery, it's going to kill off nerve endings. You know you have nerves that go to every cell of your body and of course they're going to do surgery.
You're severing those nerves. So there's some things that even if you jumped on it right away trying to do dry brushing the nerve stimulation, I think you still have the numbers. It doesn't make any difference.
So that can go away over time because there's do grow back and about I think it's like a millimeter a month.
So those can grow back and infiltrate that tissue. So but I there's not a lot more that you could do for it.
I know vitamin B6 can help with nerve pain if it's a neuropathy type thing.
You might want to consider taking some vitamin B6, but I don't know there's a whole lot you could do about that.
Run right now when I don't have it or when wait till I get it.
Well, I mean, if you're if you're symptom free right now, then maybe I wouldn't run it. I'd wait until you get it and see if that makes a difference.
The other question.
All right. Well, we will sign off for the night then.
Thanks for being on. No, I'll be praying for you guys and cherish your prayers for us and my throat as well. Thank you guys so much.
Love you all. Bye bye.